ساتوجه اليكم في لحظه مهمه معقده
وحاسمه بالنسبه لمستقبلنا وبالنسبه للعالم
برمته
هناك احداث
تاريخيه ستحدد مستقبلنا ومستقبل شعبنا كل
واحد منا لديه مسؤوليه جسيمه
قبل سنه ومن اجل ضمان امن بلدنا ومن اجل
ضمان اني مواطنين في بعض الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
والتي قامت بعد عام 2014
لاحتلال تلك المناطق نحن قمنا
بالقيام بكل الواجبات
الملقاه على عاتقنا
ومنذ عام 2014 اقليم الدومباس ناضل من اجل
الحديث بلغته ولم يتنازل لم يتنازل ابدا
امام الحصار وكراهيه نظامي كيف وهم كانوا
ينتظرون من يد العون يد العون من روسيا
وكانوا يؤمنون بوصولنا
ونحن كما تعرفون قمنا بكل ما
ينبغي من اجل حل هذه المشكله بصوره سلميه
وهادئه نحن دخلنا في مفاوضات من اجل
الخروج من هذا النزاع القاسي ولكن من خلفه
ظهرنا كان هناك سيناريو يحاك سيناريو
مختلف
الحكومات الغربيه والاوروبيه كانت تعمل
من اجل كسب الوقت ومن اجل منح الوقت لنظام
القيامه
بعمليه قتل سياسيه واعمال الاهانه واعمال
الارهاب في
اقليم الدومباس في المدرسه في المدارس
العسكريه الغربيه
كان يتم التحضير لتقديمي اسلحه
وذلك قبل القيام بهذه العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه كانت هناك
محاولات لتقديم انظمه دفاع الجوي والاسلحه
الثقيله وكل محاولاتي النظام الاوكراني
كانت تسعى ايضا الى الطلبي
مساعدتي تتعلق باسلحه النوويه
لمختبرات
بيولوجيه
وكانت اوكرانيا كانت تحضر لحرب كبيره
والان هم يعلنون ويقرون بذلك
دون اي خجل او حرج
كل ما يتعلق بصيغه النورماندي كانت خديعه
وكانت دمائه تسفكون في اقليم الدومباس
وروسيا كانت تسعى بحقه عن حل سلميه وكانت
وكانت
روسيا وكانت روسيا تؤكد على ذلك ولكن كان
هناك تلاعب بالخرائط وبالارواح
[موسيقى]
الشعوب الاخرى والجعوبهم لقد خدعوا شعوبهم
اصلا عندما قالوا بانهم كانوا يبحثون عن
حلول سلميه بما في ذلك فيما يتعلق باقليم
في الواقع كل ذلك كان عباره عن منظومه من
الاكاذيب نحن ندافع عن
مصالحنا
وعلينا ان
نتوقف عن التمييز عن البلدان التي تدعي
التحضر والبدان الاخرى
وبالتالي
يسمحوا لتلك البلدان ان تصبح
عدائيه نحن نقول باننا بحاجه الى نظام
وحيد غير قابل للتجزئه نحن نبحث
من اجل العمل معا فكنا انذاك نتلقى اجابات
اما غير واضحه او فيها نفاق
توجه اعضاء الحلف نحو حدودنا من خلال
اليات
وتشكيلات جديده
[موسيقى]
وكانوا يودون نشر منظومه
صاروخيه
والاقتراب من الحدود الروسيه
في الواقع ليس هناك اي بلد في العالم
[موسيقى]
لديه هذه القواعد خارجه بلادها الامريكيه
لديها مئات القواعد الامريكيه خارج
اراضيها وهي موجوده في كل
الكره الارضيه
رايناهم ايضا اي الامريكيون يتنازلون عن
اتفاقيات تتعلق
بالصواريخ متوسطه وبعيده المدى لماذا
يقومون بذلك قم يريدون والذي يوم هدف في
ذلك نحن في عام 2021
ارسلنا
مشروعات
اتفاقيات تتعلق بضمانات امنيه
وقمنا
ونحن تلقينا اجابه واضحه تتمثل بكلا
واضحه وهذا يعني بانهم كانوا قد اعطوا
الضوء الاخضر
للتهديد والحرب وتهديدات كانت تتزايد في
شهر فبراير عام 2022 كل شيء كان جاهزا من
اجل اطلاقي عمليه عقابيه ضد اقليم
الدومباس كانت هناك دبابات
وطائرات ونحن كنا نتذكر ذلك نتذكر تلك
الضربات على
مدن اخرى ايضا في عام 2015
حاولوا
شنه هجوم جديد على هذا الاقليم
وعلى السكان المدنيين وهذا يتعارضوا مع كل
القرارات الخاصه بمجلس الامن الدولي بهذا
الشان ولقد تم ذلك بصوره واضحه نعم هم
الذين شنوا هذه الحرب
ونحن نستخدم القوه فقط من اجل وقف هذه
الحرب
اولئك الذين كانوا يودون شن هجوم جديدا
على اقليم الدومباس كانوا
يفهمون بانه بعد ذلك سيكون هناك هجوم على
القرمه وعلى نحن لدينا اهداف نحن وكانت
هذه الاهداف واضحه بصوره واضحه من قبل كيف
نحن ندافع عن حياه الرجال
ورجالنا واما الغرب قد انفق اكثر من 150
مليار من الدولارات
كدعم مقدم لاوكرانيا
وفي عام
2021 هناك 60 مليار تم تقديمه من اجل دعم
اكثر البلدان هشاشه
لنقارن بين 150 مليار وستين مليار
وبالنسبه
للبلدان التي كانت تحصل على هذه المساعدات
كان ينبغي عليها ان تخنع
وتخضع
لارادتهم
هذه التدفقات والمساعدات العسكريه لا تكفي
وهناك ايضا اثاره للاضطرابات في عده بلد
العالم في المؤتمر الامني في ميونخ كانت
هناك
هجمات ضد روسيا
وكل ذلك كان يهدف الى الى الى الى الى
النسياني ما قام به الغرب ضد روسيا
والخبراء الامريكيون يقولون
[موسيقى]
بان هذه الحرب لانه بعد الحروب التي شنت
بعد عام 2001
هناك اكثر من 9 00 الف
قتلوا
والكثير والكثير الكثير
اصبحوا نازحين ولاجئين هذا لا يمكن مسح
ذلك من ذاكره الانسانيه هم يريدون ان ننسى
كل ذلك ولكن لا احد سينسى ذلك
ان هذه الماساه
وهذه الكوارثه
من الدولارات يتم صرفها
ويتم الحديث عن انظمه ديمقراطيه ولكن في
الواقع هي انظمه استبداديه
ويتم
رسم هذه الصوره للعدو من اجل اخفاء كل
فضائح الفساد
والتي
تتعلق بمشاكل داخليه اقتصاديه
وفي بدايه القرن
العشرين ان المشاريع الغربيه التي فتحت
المجال للنازيه وهذه
المشروعات حاليا اليوم هي يعاد تكرارها
نرى
نرى كل هذا الدمار
وفيما يتعلق باراده تدمير روسيا ونزع
اوكرانيا
وهذا الحلم نفسه هو الحلم المتمثل في
الماضي وفي تاريخ بالامبراطوريه النمساويه
الالمانيه
وفي عام 2014 كان هناك انقلاب غير دستوريه
اذن ولكن هذا لم
يحقق اهدافه
ان كراهيه
روسيا هي اساس هذه
العقيده
هذه الوحدات الخاصه
للقوات الاوكرانيه وهذا فيه الكثير من
العار ونحن نشعر بالعار عندما
ندرك بان هذه الوحدات الخاصه الاوكرانيه
تحمل اسم
الوحدات
الالمانيه التي المحتله
وهناك رموز
الشرطه السريه النازيه
الموجوده والمرسومه على الدبابات
والمدرعات الاوكرانيه بالاضافه الى الرموز
النازيه الجديده
ونرى تماما ما هي هؤلاء اما في الغرب لا
يتم الانتباه لذلك لماذا
هؤلاء لا يبالون لذلك نعم هم لا يرثون
لذلك لماذا هم فقط ما يهمهم هو مكافحه
روسيا ومحاربه روسيا ان يهمهم ان تكون
هناك حرب ضدها روسيا وهم يستخدمون كل ما
هو موجود في ايديهم ومن ادوات
يستخدمون الارهابيين واخرين لا يهم طالما
حملوا سلاح ضد روسيا ان مناهضه روسيا هو
هي جزء من هذا الانتقام الروسيا اي انشاء
بؤر للنزاع على حدود بلدنا وهذه الاهداف
هي ذاتها والتي يتم متابعتها منذ القرن
العشرين اي توجيهه الهجمات والانشطه ضد
روسيا نحن لا نشن حربا على شعب
الاوكرانيين نحن نعرف بان هذا الشعب كان
رهينه للنظام كييف
لرؤساء اهم وارباب عملهم الغربيين من اجل
الاستيلاء على هذا البلد من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه لقد قوضوا الصناعه الاوكرانيه
ونهبوا الموارد الطبيعيه
وساهموا في تخريب الوضع الاجتماعي
وتفاقم انعدام المساواه
وهناك حاجه الى مواد اوليه من اجل القيام
بهذه العمليات الحربيه هؤلاء لقد استعدوا
من اجل استخدام الاوكرانيين كذخيره حرب
هذا محزن ولكن يجب قول ذلك هذه المسؤوليه
هذه المسؤوليه في هذا التصعيد هي مسؤوليه
النخب الغربيه ومسؤوليه نظام كافه هذا
النظام الغريب عن الشعب الاوكراني في
الواقع هذا النظام لا يخدم مصالح شعبي
ولكن
يخدم مصالح بلدان اخرى هذه البلدان الاخرى
التي تستخدم هذا البلد كدرع ضد ضد روسيا
ربما يودون ان يشنوا هجمات جديده فكلما
تم ارسال اسلحه بعيده المدى
الى اوكرانيا
طالما نحن توجب علينا ابعادهم ابعد من
حدودنا ان النخب
الغربيه لا تخفي اهدافها هم يريدون الحصول
على فجر استراتيجي
لروسيا ما الذي يعني ذلك ان يتم وضع حد
بصوره نهائيه لروسيا اي ان هذا النزاع
المحلي ان
يتم العمل عليه كموازاه مع هذه المواجهه
الكامله ونحن سنرد على ذلك
بالطريقه المناسبه لان الامر هنا يتعلق
بوجود بلد لا يستطيعون الا يدركوا ذلك من
المستحيل هزيمه روسيا عسكريا
ولذلك فهم
يقومون بهجمات في المجال
الاعلامية الاجتماعي وهم يستهدفون الشباب
ونحن نراهم يحاولون ان يزيفوا الوقائع
التاريخيه ويستمرون في هجماتهم على
تاريخنا وعلى الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه الروسيه
ولكن ماذا يفعلون اذا شعوبهم عندما يتم
تدمير وتقويض مفاهيم الاسره والثقافه
في الواقع ان
التحرش بالغلمان والاطفال اصبح قيمه من
قيميهم
وايضا يباركون
زواج مثلي الجنس لديهم
[موسيقى]
بطبيعه الحال
نحن ندرك بانه بان الكبار يتصرفون كما
يحلو لهم ولكن هنا علينا ان نقر ونعترف
لننظر الى الكتابات المقدسه لننظر الى
المبادئ وتعاليم كل الديانات
واقوالوها والتي تؤكد بان العائله والاسره
والزواج هو هي علاقه بين رجل وامراه
وحتى هذه النصوص المقدسه هي في الواقع يتم
استهدافها والشك والشك فيها
الكنيسه الامريكيه
تريد انشاء
صوره اله
اله من نوع غير محدد الجنس هم لا يعرفون
ماذا يفعلون في الواقع الملايين من الناس
في الغرب
لا يعرفون بانهم يسيرون نحو كارثه روحانيه
والنخب في تلك البلدان
يغرقون في ضرب من الجنون
ولكن علينا نحن ان نحمي اطفالنا ضد هذا
الانحراف وضد هذا
الاصول
وبالتالي الغرب سيحاول ان يزعزع
اركانها مجتمعاتنا وهم اساء يعولون في ذلك
على
الخونه الذين الذين لا يحترمون بلدهم
يقومون
بوضع انفسهم تحت خدمه الاخرين وبالتالي هم
يختارون الخيانه
وبالتالي نحن سنختار
التاكيد على الامن مجدي حمايه بلداننا نحن
الساعه نعمل نحن لن نقوم بالقضاء اولئك
الذين يخرجون عن الطريق او ولكن نحن سنؤكد
على
التعامل معهم بالتاكيد على الجانب
الوجداني ولكن ينبغي على المواطنين الروس
ان يكونوا
ان يكونوا ويؤكدوا على طريقه تصرفاتهم
بصوره صحيحه وان شعبنا المتعدد الاعراقي
والمذاهب
عليه ان يتفهم اهدافنا
وطموحاتنا نحن نعمل من اجل وطنيه حقيقيه
هذا الشعور الوطني
التاريخي الذي هو جزء لا يتجزا من الشعب
الروسي
وهو وهذا يبين وفيه الكثير من الكرامه مع
التحلي بهذه الاراده من اجل التاكيد
والخلط بين المصير الفردي والمصير الامه
ايها المواطنون انا اشكركم جميعا اشكركم
على شجاعتكم
ومثابردكم اشكر الطاعه
الجيش
والبري والبحريه والحرس
والمتطوعين
واشكر ايضا كل اولئك الذين يشاركون في
مجموعات بارس واريد ان
وانا اعجز عن اعداد كل الاسماء الوحدات
عندما قمت بالتحضير بهذا الخطاب
كانت لدي قائمه طويله بكل الوحدات
المقاتله وعد واكرر من الساحه من الصعب
جدا ان احصيها جميعا
وبالتالي لا اريد ان انسى احدا اريد اشكر
هنا العائلات الزوجات الامهات واقدموا لهن
تحياتي وقدم تحياتي ايضا للاطباء
ولمساعدي الرعايه الطبيه والممرضات
والعاملين السكه في السكك الحديديه
واقدم ايضا تحياتي الى المهندسين المدنيين
الذين يقومون باعاده بناء البنى التحتيه
ومن يعملون في الانشاءات والذين يعملون 24
ساعه على 24 ساعه واشكر ايضا كل المزارعين
والفلاحين الذين يقومون بضمان الامن
الغذائي ببلادنا واريد اشكر ايضا الاساتذه
والمعلمين الذين يعملون من اجل بناء
الاجيال القادمه والذين يعملون ايضا في
ظروف صعبه جدا في مقربه من الحدود واشكر
ايضا كل الاثار الفاعله في مجال الثقافه
الذين يقومون
العروض في المستشفيات المدخل الاخرى واشكر
ايضا الصحفيين الحربيين الذين يسردون
الحقيقه للعالم برمته
واشكر ايضا رجال الدين
والخوارنه هو الحاء الى جانب المقاتلين
اشكر ايضا المقاولين وارباب العمل والذين
يطلعون بدورهم المهنيه والمدنيه
والانسانيه وعلى وجه الخصوص اريد
ان اتوجه الى
سكاني
مناطقسون
لقد
قمتم
وصوتتم بشان مستقبلكم
[موسيقى]
وانتم موجوده بمحاذاه المعارك ان
قراركم وعزيمتكم هي عزيمه قويه
بكونكم اردتم ان تكونوا مع بلدكم روسيا
ونحن سنستمر في ذلك
اريد ان اذكر هنا بان هذا الرد طبيعي من
القاعه هو رد موجه
لمناطق
هي اشاده بهم وانا اضم صوتي الى صوتكم
للاشهاده بهم
وهناك خطه لتطوير موضوعات جديده في اطار
الاتحاد الروسي علينا اعاده
الحماسه
الديناميكيه لدى هذه الشركات من اجل بناء
مشعار جديده وطرق جديده كما في شبه
الجزيره القرمه حيث هناك شبكه اتصالات
ومواصلات بريه
جيده ونحن سنستمر العمل في هذه المناطق من
اجل دعمها ومساندتها
هذه المناطق الاربعه
نحن ها نحن مجددا معا وسنكون اقوى معا
وسنقوم بكل ما نستطيع حتى تصبح هذه الارض
التي هي ارضنا لتصبح ارض سلام حتى يتم
ضمان الامن فيها
[تصفيق]
وذلك من اجل اسلافينا ومن اجل
الاجيال القادمه من اجل
احقاق الحق مجددا من اجل وبالتالي
فابطالنا وجنودنا يقاتلون اطلب منكم
الوقوف
تمجيدا
لاولئك الذين ضحوا بحياتهم ولكل المدنيين
الذين قتلوا تحت القصف
شكرا
وندرك مدى صعوبه التي تواجهها الزوجات
والامهات
الامهات اللواتي يفقدن ازواجهن وابنائهن
ولا
غير اولئك الذين شاركوا في الحرب
العالميه الذين قاوم النازيه في اقليم
الدمباس وهم يدركون قيمه هذه التضحيات
ويعملون بذلك بصوره وبروحانيه كبيره جدا
من ينبغي مساعده اولئك الذين فقدوا
احبائهم
وذلك من اجل وبناء اجيال جديده ينبغي
رعايتهم
وتقديم العون لهم
وبكثير من الكرامه
صندوق دولي صندوقا عفوا
حكومي وطني من اجل تقديم العون
ضحايا
هذه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه سواء كان هذا
العون في المجال الصحي او النفسيه او
العطلات او في المجال الرياضي او العمل في
مجال المهني وتلقي التدريب المهني وهذا
صندوق الوطني
سيقوم ايضا بتقديم مساعده منزليه ولا سيما
من خلال
الانظمه المتعلقه بالاطراف الاصطناعيه او
الاجهزه الاخرى في هذا المجال
القيام بكل هذا العمل والتنظيم تنظيمه هذه
هذا صندوق صندوق الوطني
تنبغي ان تكون الاجراءات سهله جدا من خلال
النافذه موحده يتوجه
الاسر المعنيه
ولا سيما اقارب
المقاتلين الذين فقدوا حياتهم او
المحاربين القدماء
ينبغي متابعه ورعايه كل الاشخاص المعنيين
بصوره فرديه وشخصيه وينبغي حل مشى اكلهم
واعتبارا من هذه السنه فان هياكل هذا
الصندوق سيتم توزيعها ونشرها لتعمل على كل
الاراضي الروسيه
هناك اصلا مساعده مقدمه للمحاربين القدماء
الذين شاركوا في الحرب العالميه وهذه
الصندوق هذا صندوق ايضا سيتكفل بهذه
الانشطه ايضا اطلب من افراد الحكومه اعضاء
الحكومه ان يتولوا وان يعملوا في هذا
المجال
ينبغي العمل ايضا
اطلب من كل السلطات المحليه والمعنيه من
اجل تقديم الرعايه للمحاربين القدامى
والعسكريين على رؤساء البلديات على سبيل
المثال ورؤساء الاقاليم والمناطق
ان
يتوجه الى خطوط الجبهه من اجل تقديم الدعم
المعنوي الوطنيين والمواطنين هناك
فيما يتعلق بمن تم تعبئتهم
وحشتهم والمسائل الاخرى المتعلقه بالتموين
والضمانه ينبغي تامين كل ذلك انا اعرف
واتفهم ونظرا الاتصالات التي وصلتني
والنداءات التي وصلتني انا ادرك بان هذه
الطلبات لا يتم تلبيتها كما يكفي والكم
يتفهم ذلك ان هذه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
هي تفضي الى اعباء ثقيله جدا على كل طرف
من الاطراف وعلى كل جهه من الجهات بالتالي
ينبغي
كل الاطراف وتعبيئتهم في هذا المجال حتى
يستطيع افراد هذه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
والمتطوعين ان يحصلوا
على استراحات لمده 14 يوم على الاقل كل
سته اشهر حتى يستطيع كل عسكري ان ياخذ
استراحته ويعود الى عائلته ليستريح لعده
ايام اسئله والساده نحن لدينا خطه
خطه من اجل اعاده الاعمار
وتطوير العمليات العسكريه للعام
2021-2025 هذه الخطه يتم مراجعتها اليوم
من اجل تعزيز القوات المسلحه والقوات
البحريه ومن اجل ايضا تطوير هذه
الاقوات
وللقيام بذلك علينا ان
نرتكز على الخبره العسكريه المستنبطه من
هذه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه هذا درس مهم
جدا
فيما يتعلق
بتجهيزات والمعدات
خاصه بالقوات النوويه
هناك نسبه مهمه جدا في هذا المجال تصل
لواحد وتسعين بالمئه فيما يتعلق
بالاستبعاد
ويجب ان تكون هذه النسبه لاستعداد موجوده
في كل التشكيلات العسكريه ان الضباط وصف
الضباط الذين بينوا عن قدراتهم في القياده
والاداره وهؤلاء هم كثيرون جدا وهذه
اولويه اولويه
بالنسبه
لهم
وينبغي هنا التاكيد على الدورات التدريبيه
وتاهيليه الضروريه في المجالات للعمل في
المجالات المختلفه
هذا الامر مهم جدا على هؤلاء الرجال
هؤلاء الافراد عليهم ان يدركوا بان بلدهم
هو قادر على الاقرار والاعتراف بخبراتهم
المكتسبه
ينبغي ايضا تحسين قدرات القوات المسلحه
ولدينا نحن
التجهيزات التقنيه ذات جوده عاليه وهي
اعلى بكثير في بعضها مقارنه بنظراتها
الاجنبيه ينبغي تطوير الانتاج بصوره كبيره
جدا انتاج هذه الاسلحه وهذه المعدات بصوره
سنقوم بذلك استنادا الى قدراتنا ومعارفنا
الفنيه والعلميه سيكون هنا ايضا تطوير
للطلبيات العسكريه وهناك مكاتب دراسيه
التي تعمل بالتعاون مع المصانع التسليه
العسكريه التي تتعاقد مع الشباب الموهوبين
الاوفياء
لتقاليدنا نعم المهندسون الذين يعملون قدر
استطاعتهم من اجل الانتصار نحن سنقوم ايضا
بتعزيز الضمانات للعاملين
فيما يتعلق بالاسعار على العاملين ان تكون
لديهم اجور ولاسيما العاملين في مجال
الصناعات العسكريه فهؤلاء العمال يجب ان
يحصلوا على منازل ومساكن باجور
مدعومه من الحكومه نحن سنتحدث بهذا الشان
مع اعضاء الحكومه ينبغي تطوير هذا
البرنامج بكل تفاصيلهم وهذه
هذه المساكن
المدعومه من الحكومه ينبغي انشاؤها في
المناطق القريبه من المصانع ومراكز تطوير
الاسلحه وهذا ليس عمل عسكريه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وهم لا يواجهوننا في المجال العسكري ولكن
هم يواجهوننا على المستوى الاقتصادي ولكن
هم لم يحصلوا على اي شيء عن طريق العقوبات
هؤلاء الذين بادروا بتلك العقوبات انما
يعاقبون انفسهم اليوم هذا الامر افضى الى
اغلاق المصانع ولديهم ازمه في مجال الطاقه
وشعبهم تقول هم يقولون لشعوبهم بان هذا هو
الذنب هو ذنب روسيا ما الذي تم
استخدامه في هذا الاعتداء
لقد تم قطر العلاقات مع شركات الروسيه
المجالات الاطراف العامله في مجال
الاقتصادي
وتم ايضا قتل العلاقات بين الشركات
وجبائني
من العملات الاجنبيه هم
حذفهم الاساسيه هدفهم الاساسيه في البلدان
الغربيه هدفون الى
معاناتي مواطنين هم يريدون من مواطنين ان
يعانوا هذه انسانيتهم هم يريدون نشر يريد
زعزعه مجتمعاتنا
وعلينا ان نقيم حتى نبين بانهم على خطا ان
مقاومه اقتصادينا هو اقوى بكثير مما كان
يتوقعونها وذلك بفضل عمل الحكومه
والبرلمان والمصرف المركزي وايضا
المؤسسات ارباب العمل والمجموعات
الاقتصاديه المختلفه مختلفه هذه
العقوبات لم تؤثر
بنا
ولم تفضي الى
الغياب المواد الاساسيه بشكل من الاشكال
تم
ارسال تم اعتماد مبادرات من اجل دعم
الشركات تم صرف تريليون من الروبيلات في
هذا المجال اريد هنا انا
انتباهكم الامر لا يتعلق بطبع العملات كلا
انها عمليه تمويل قائمه على اقتصاد حقيقي
وفي عام
2021 كان هناك تقليص في اجمال الناتج
المحليه
كانت هناك معلومات تم نشرها البارحه
وهذا كله ياتي وفقا لمشروع
يدبرونه
وكان بمجرد بذلك كانوا يقولون بان اقتضنا
سينهار ولكن في عام
وعشرين هناك هناك تقلص في اجمال الناتج
المحلي بنسبه جدا في السنه الماضيه كان
يقال بان اقتصادنا سنهار كيف تم ذلك ان
الشركات قامت بتغيير طريقه عملها من خلال
اتصالي مع زبائنا ذات موثوقيه من جميع
انحاء العالم
اعتبارا مقارنه ديسمبر عام 2021 هناك
مساعدات
ازدادت
بالتعاملات
بالعملات الاجنبيه مع البلدان الصديق زادت
بصوره واضحه وقمنا بايجاد انظمه دوليه من
شانها ان تكون مستقله عن الدولار وعن
العملات الاخرى
وبالتالي هذه العملات تفقد جانبها وطابعها
الدولي وهذا كله
بسببهم
وجاء بسبب خطئهم في
نعم اولئك الذين هم الذين ارتكبوا هذا
الخطا بانفسهم
عن اي بلد هي اولويه في هذا المجال لن
نكرر اخطاء الماضي لن نقوم
بنفس الاخطاء سنقوم بكل شيء من اجل الضمان
اقتصاد وتنميه امنه لبلادنا ونحن سنستمر
في هذا الاتجاه وسنعمل في هذا الاتجاه
[تصفيق]
ات
في الواقع
واياكم جانبا من هذه من هذا الخطاب لرئيس
الروسي امام الجمعيه الاتحاديه